there is only one profile of a bandit in
our country which is a profile of the black
youngster from the outskirts of the community
but we have a profile that is even
more dangerous he is rich he is
white and he rules in brazil
my name is diogo silva só
olympic athlete is in pain I went to two
olympic games and my mission now is to
talk about subjects that brazil doesn't
like to talk
about society has a look at the
community from a bad place from an
ugly place from a violent place from a place
dangerous
in fact the vast majority of
people are workers very forced people
I had, mainly in my
adolescence,
many problems with this mainly
with racism with police violence
I always address these issues but I
could not go into depth because the
sponsors do not want the presidents
of the companies  confederations don't want me I was
constantly pressured as an athlete it
is extremely important that people
first know that this exists